tiens tu me donnes le poème ma voix et
puis je te donne la coupe est un oiseau
one fille nom poupée pour les filles
voiture pour les garçons les clichés
autour des jouets pour enfants ont la
vie dure
/ de couleur le rose et le bleu les
jouets véhicules depuis longtemps une
image stéréotypée en 1958 par exemple
ghislaine apprenait à devenir une bonne
maman grâce à sa coupe et copie fidèle
d'une vraie chaise de bébé en jouant et
sans le savoir ghislaine prend ainsi
l'habitude de l'hygiène du confort d'un
matériel moderne de puériculture défi
bonne ménagère face à des garçons
fonceur bricoleur bagarreur dans leurs
rayons les jouets figurines de guerre
sont d'ailleurs bien présent le début de
la virilité
selon ce responsable de magasin en 1976
c'est un petit peu la musculature modèle
que chaque garçon de 12 ou 13 ans
voudrait avoir quand il sera un peu plus
vieux
rien que ça ce conditionnement des
enfants par les jouets étaient déjà
dénoncée par cet éducateur en 1978 selon
lui l'adulte en était le premier
responsable
ja du projet toujours ses propres idées
c'est propre idéologie ses propres
pensées culturel d'un jouet
en fait quand on a essayé de laisser
jouer librement des garçons et des
filles on ne constate pas de différence
mais le diktat des jeux stéréotypés
reste toujours d'actualité
écoutez le constat amer de cette
spécialiste du jouet en 2004 les gars
sont donc absolument pas le droit et
n'ont toujours pas le droit de jouer
avec des poupées cia une poupée pour la
petite soeur il a le droit de jouer avec
mais on n'achète pas de poupées aux
petits garçons parce que derrière il ya
cette crainte exprimée de
l'homosexualité masculine
aujourd'hui plusieurs enseignes de
jouets pour des efforts pour gommer ses
clichés dans les rayons et dans les
magazines
car comme le disait cette institutrice
en 1978
le jeu c'est la sphère des enfants les
grandes personnes n'ont pas à s'en mêler
[Musique]